and then afterwards we'll open it up for
discussion
our first speaker is Harriet Jackson who
also is obviously one of the
co-organizers eventually this conference
was really a very good site so we really
thank her received her master's of
philosophy degree from NYU and she
suspended years studying of the
apologies of the to be on sosial in
Paris her MA thesis dealt with the topic
of the rise of anti-semitism in France
in the 30s and she's also published an
essay on the impact of the First World
War
social security in France she spent most
of her career working in publishing and
she were chair and will be out for
several years on a project called the
electronic publishing initiative
more recently she spent time working an
EVO here in New York City the Institute
of these European Jewish Studies bitter
she helped you can watch some of the
collections if they have not yet catalog
on French Jewish history during the
Holocaust he or she came across the
papers of their lives of Engineers and
the founder of associazione
because in Paris in 1936 and finally
well and her talk today is going to be
based on the archival documents she
discovered while working at Evo in
addition I think you some other
documentation and the title of your talk
today is once a Hasidic rabbi like you
doing in a place like this
okay well I'm here to talk about it
fascinating character into telling the
truth but you know hiring me to work on
the papers of a Pacific rabbi I try was
boring for that be and he is one of the
most interesting people I have ever
studied and what impressed me
immediately was when I learned that as
soon as he came to Paris from the Soviet
Union within a few months he in
stablished philanthropy a social service
agency for practicing Jews will be
absolutely has to tell me he sent me to
cut seek off and I thought you know
there's my language of Paris
with him the second thing that I have to
say is some people think that when I
when I speak about rabbi exalted
Shearson that I'm talking about the
leader of the mature has it except what
is Menachem Mendel Schneerson was called
the RIBA I am I'm not talking about him
and I am also not talking about Isaac
Shearson who founded the state a she's a
research center in parents however all
three men all three schneerson's were
her cousins distant cousins so they
weren't related as maybe told you the
this research is based on evil but I was
also a general thoughts of study at the
joint and this supposed to be about some
oral testimony now the story of rabbi
schneerson's wartime activities reasons
so important in historiographical
questions about resistance and rescue in
Vichy France and in particular about the
role played by Jewish individuals and
organizations his story is compelling
because
voices that he's faced and the
strategies he adopted help us understand
the limits the limited range of choices
dilemmas and strategy is faced by
rescuers of Jews in Vichy France so
there is something remarkably different
that says rabbi Schneerson story apart
from that of any other Jewish leader lay
or religious and what distinguishes him
from the others are two major influences
first his religious observance
he was Hasidic his religious observance
informed his decisions we cannot
understand the man without being
familiar with Judaism and Judaic law
second this is really important his cut
destined experience and the Hasidic Jew
in Soviet Russia also informed the
clandestine work that he undertook in
Vichy in other words he came to France
with prior resistance training so in
today's presentation I would like to
focus on five star ethical questions
that are raised by rabbi Schneerson
story and again his story helps us
understand the larger story of relief
rescue and resistance so now you know
books your pens the
with and I just want to show you some
photographs up slightly sheer stood so
ravish years that is to the left
he's with a friend next one rabbi
Schneerson to get us on the left and
this is a ceremony with the joint n stop
American US Army chocolates right after
the war
this is Hadassah Kalbach the daughter of
rabbi Schneerson and when she was a
teenager in SWA home she hid one of
these small groups of children and fast
forward 6070 years forward you can see
that she is right here in the auditorium
oh and this is our evidence our Shearson
the the wife of Rama Salman she near sit
and she's really very important I wish I
could find out more about her because
she was instrumental in helping her
husband as was Hadassah in performing
research I've been performing rescues
and okay the next one oh okay so this is
show libéré Hadassah is younger brother
so he was a bit about sister eat she's
standing next to him but she okay he had
to leave the Soviet Union because he was
doing a lot of clandestine activity in
the 1920s and the 1930s and yes I'll get
to that and he kind of activities your
electric practice Judaism
he was circulating American currency
that he got from the joint and that
alone would have earned him the death
penalty the secret police came to visit
their house on many occasions surprise
visit and her father I was talkin stuff
out of an arrest was just always calm
and he knew how to pretend that he
wasn't a rabbi that he didn't have to
date books and
I think he was like a tailor he
pretended he was a tailor and how he had
to leave in Hobart ographers
okay and so by 1935 it was clear that he
had to leave but his life was at risk
and the the voucher Reba at the time
suggested that he go to Palestine
British Palestine so he went with the
family in 1935 he disliked it very much
it's being too communist for him so he
went back to the lubavitcher rebbe a--
who was in poland at the time so this is
still 1935 and he said I don't like this
Palestine you know thank you can you
send me somewhere else
and he was sent to Paris so he arrives
in Paris actually 1935 and his family
joins him in
thirty-six and then again within a few
months of his arrival in Paris he sets
up this association and what does this
association do between 1936 and 1948
sets up ISM Hebrew schools at least two
synagogues and at least two soup
kitchens and these activities are funded
by the joint and this is very important
because the American Jewish Jewish Joint
Distribution Committee had been a major
funder if not the major funder of Jewish
organizations in Europe so come back to
my five it is very graphical questions
and the first thing that I would like to
ask is or think about we know that
foreign Jews were particularly targeted
by Vichy from the beginning of the
occupation and they faced enormous
obstacles just to survive practically
one out of every two foreign Jews
perished as a result of the vicious role
in the Holocaust
how is rabbi Schneerson able not only to
survive the entire war but to also
perform relief and rescue for so many
co-religionists
- did relief organizations help
perpetuate the system of internment and
Reaver caps and they and can they be
considered collaborationist 3 what
strategies did jewish organizations such
as schneerson's what do they do to adopt
to survive and what constraints did they
face as the circumstances of the war and
the nature of collaboration changed from
1940 to 1944 there's anything that we
learned here at the conference is the
changing circumstances of the war in
France in 1940 was completely different
from France and November 1944 and again
completely different than September 1943
for question our training what was the
nature of the Vichy government at the
local level
how are people like ravish Pearson able
to obtain help from local Vichy
officials and five when is the end
the most important themes of the
conference when's rescue considered
rescue when does rescue count and who
decides it is not about two historians
to judge but I will apply to historians
tools to understand the motives and
achievements of one man and then situate
his story of resistance in the larger
story of the sheep France so you know
let's get the part about his coming from
an illustrious family in in in Russia
that he was involved in the clandestine
activities and they came to Paris I'll
just start immediately with more so
within days of the French defeat major
Jewish organizations led Paris they set
up new headquarters in the Jewish
quarter of mocs day so some of these
Jewish organizations are high acid
Hebrew Hebrew even breathe through the
Aid Society the point again the
classy comp which I'll just refer to
with the with its acronym a IP and car
which way they're sort of turned it to
you see they were all located in this
area of masse these Jewish organizations
while in Paris have forged important
relationships before the war to help
Jewish refugees and these relationships
even under stress under wartime
conditions continued and the joint
renamed their principle their principal
benefactor throughout the war years as a
matter of fact the joint
financed the AI ep's activities
throughout the war up to about fifty
percent so these Jewish organizations
were faced with the incredible problem
of what to do with the refugees during
the first winter
1940-41 during the first winter there
were tens of thousands of foreign Jews
incarcerated the beeshees internment
camps and hundreds were dying from
horrific living conditions so they
thought they had to do something so they
said there were many things that we did
which you heard about during a
conference and specifically the AIP
rabbi Schneerson that sent care packages
500 to 800 per month and for small
organization you know one-man operation
500 to 800 care packages in a lot he
also tried to release some of the intern
Jews by either helping them integrate
find jobs or enrolling them in the
vocational schools that Shearson set up
in masse and the oort helped him set up
one of them now in addition rabbi
Schneerson the musicians provide a
relief rabbi Schneerson ran a communal
home for children of practicing Jews and
he had to move to the home several times
during the war as conditions became more
dangerous so he set up the first
he said of the first children's home
outside of BC and he says the subject bo
say that partnership didn't last long
that help feeling that he he was his own
boss
and the only he'll be reported to
himself and then shortly is over there
cube within a few months he set up
another home in Knox a which which
existed there from October 1940 until
November 1942 when the Germans occupied
the zone normal keeping it what's really
interesting is that within two or three
days of a German
invasion he was able to get all of the
children they were about 60 at the time
his staff which must have been at least
five and his family for so we're talking
about a group of 70 people he was able
to get them out of the box a and safely
to a town called Jim you just nuts are
from Toulouse and what's amazing is that
he was able to get travel passes for
everyone which is something that was
very difficult to do during the war but
he had he had connections of the present
to now fast forward he's in he's into
new for a few months the American
Quakers and the Red Cross helped him you
know set up provides some supplies some
blankets but a few months later in March
he was tipped off that it wasn't really
safe and so in March actually the day
after poram he again moved everyone to
doís home and in March 1943 as you know
why all was safe because it was under
Italian jurisdiction so the the Jews
there were saved from the court
so that was you know a smart move to go
to walk home in as you know September
1943 with the Italian surrendering the
Italian Army surrender into the Allies
the Jews in the Italian sector were
understandably worried and wanted to
follow the Italian army into Italy and
most of them thousands got stuck in meat
so they got stuck because the Gestapo
and this she gave it organized a huge
roundup
and so the schneerson's the children the
staff were were entrapped there for two
or three weeks and what's really
interesting is that lay employer caught
who you've heard of the employer Huff is
a historian of anti-semitism during the
war years during 1941 and 1942 he was
the right-hand man of rabbi Schneerson
and
his memoirs employee post memoirs he
writes about the the rabbi and how he
you know he was always on twenty four
twenty four seventy of his incredible
energy
the one negative portrayal is that they
bought your thoughts was a secular Jew
and he couldn't understand someone being
religious let alone Orthodox so he just
thought it was really peculiar when we
would be doing his office work and then
rabbi Schneerson would you know sort of
like pulled him in like we need a minion
we need a video so you know the first
question is how did how did smear sin
here he has he is a he's far he's an
outsider he's not part of some of the
French religious organizations such as
one for example is the Omer game you
know where they are the the these
reappointed chaplains like army
chaplains
today was to go into the camps and they
and they and other kinds of secular
social security religious social welfare
organizations tries to provide relief
for the intern and we saw this in TXO
botches film last night there's one
occasion and this might sound frivolous
to you but there's one occasion 1942
occasions 1941 and 1942 oh you can yes
yes oh this is what is one of the
children's home and next one again it's
another another children's home you can
see he he haven't set up in you know
nice real estate here we have these are
images that I got from the US Holocaust
Museum in in DC and it shows religious
Jews for performing Shabbat during these
and weekend
and so you can see the depressions and
and oh okay so rabbi Schneerson in the
open he makes sure that not only did
they have food but they had the ritual
items and okay on the question of
whether or not I should say that here to
historian chef odd lamb and out of race
be who who think that they believe that
the organizations that helped provide
relief to the internees were actually
perpetuating the the camp system because
they were not resisting he she they were
actually submitting themselves to be she
the historians like susan is a cook tea
and Vicki Karen however argue that you
know it's really unfair to accuse these
organizations before September 1942 of
knowing of the final solution of No
the internment camps would ultimately be
used for you know extermination the
third issue I raised is again this you
know the question of complicity and that
is the Germans
it's the Hannah Arendt thesis about the
you tonight
and there are some people who or
historians who think that the Russia
which was an umbrella organization that
was imposed by the Germans on the French
some consider this umbrella organization
and being blinded so they do not do they
get housed in in the East but I don't
see it that that way and I see I don't
have time to explain why
okay one point that I do want to to make
is and we became clear at the conference
that September 19 fourth that the summer
of 1942 when the massive deportation
started that this was a turning point
for Jewish organizations when they
realized this is it we have to we have
to go underground we have to get
involved in clandestine activities and
what I want to say is that Cheniere said
was a little bit more savvy than the
others and earlier so for example in
1941 it might say he was already
involved in in manufacturing false
papers and Joseph bats as Susan thought
you spoke about this morning who you
know headed the rescue network they so
there's at least one say he actually
Joseph asked came to fierce in asking
for help and if they employ your folks
who who writes about this and then there
are some ones you know other side
but he did before you know this turning
point and what I would like to argue is
that because of his resistance
experience in the Soviet Union he wasn't
it wasn't - and you know how to
manipulate the bureaucracy and whereas
one could say that the French Jewish
leaders like hell brother and mom bail
up until a certain point hoped that she
could somehow offers some kind of buffer
between the Jewish community and the
Germans that illusion completely
disappeared by the time of the
deportations in 1942 and I think that
she ursin was on to that earlier because
he started clandestine activities in in
1941 there's okay there's something
that's very important and it's something
that bothers me because there's very
limited work Shearson in the
historiography they're about three story
ins who have written
about repeat and they have included
information about Shearson there's some
other historians a little bit harsh and
blame him for a Gestapo roundup that
occurred on March 23rd 1944 and the
criticism is that the Shearson didn't
disperse the children earlier into what
I would like to point out again is the
the limitations that they were working
under and as a matter of fact she ursin
started out with about 60 children when
he left nice you know after the Gestapo
you know roundup he left nice actually
thanks to the southeast home today and
he was able to bring everyone back to
Guam so about 60 children the staff
at that point September 1943 they go
underground
they hide and the the children aren't
allowed to be seen and they're not
allowed to you know come out of the
house that it was Hadassah as a teenager
who and a few of her father's receiver
boys you know they were on their
bicycles and provided communications
provided medicine between all of these
hiding places and and so what I'd like
to point out is that in fact between
September and March 1944 all of the
children have been smuggled across to
Switzerland and Schneerson was involved
in a rescue network that was that was
involved with mental Oh Mandel Mantello
who was responsible for trying to rescue
of an Aryan Jews and it's tragic that
the 18 children who had been arrested by
the Gestapo in here at not master yao at
this home is it's tragic that they were
found out
have denounced them but they were slated
to be smuggled across the Swiss border a
few days later and the documentation
about that is having to do with
certificates that - I don't have the
time to go into and also correspondence
between Shearson and a French lawyer but
- laughs with whom they had a close
relationship when they were in my stay
in 1942 because both of these men headed
Orthodox Jewish organizations and much
fear of mullah had to escape to
Switzerland after you know the Germans
invaded in November 1942 and then left
here Oh mullah worked very closely with
Mantello Mandel who was a Hungarian Jew
who was creating certificates to false
papers to try to
help the children get smuggled across to
Switzerland and so we do now that some
of the some sheer since children made it
to to Switzerland and I guess I will
conclude by saying that you know the
fact that there was this this tragedy
seems to trump all his other activities
such as performing relief and in fact
rescuing at least 40 others and between
1940 and 1944 there were hundreds of
children who had passed through his home
maybe they stayed for a few months maybe
they stayed for a year and I know that
one of my Paul TL had visited the home
and the one one summer for a very short
time in Missouri in ma stay and and
Bertha Schwartz was hidden by by sneers
and as a matter of fact right after the
summer deportations in clear to
Schneerson that the the Jews in
Marseilles
you know had to be enhancing a rescue
that you know as quick as possible the
children have to be smuggled out and
actually a few days before Bertha and
her sisters were slated for deportation
to Paul C she nears incentives her she
avoids to you know pick her up you know
and her sister so he lights up Dan
particularly the image of the religious
Jew as they have to figure in victim on
the contrary rather sheer sins like
story it's representative of the
proactive and clandestine role that
Hassidim played in Czarist and soviet
russia he brought this experience of
resistance to the sheep France and
succeeded in inserting himself in the
nexus of reeds activity in deity and in
saving Jewish children and as a result
of this study we have a better
understanding of Vichy at the local
level and the real constraints that
Jewish organizations face of Vichy
France
like he's been the expert on the Allianz
he's written many books and articles on
French Jewish history among his most
recent works our massive husky dog April
Great Valley ox is very to herself and
then went alone which came out in 2000
he's also co-authored with roll-on
murray noma survived a beat
missile onto his 56 way in which is a
collection of still bound baby's letters
to Jon Scheyer broth and Jack the art of
the aliens and then appeared in 2010 and
most would be somebody is co-author in
Kentucky
entitled and the salmon mousse I'm de
Lumiere which is appearing imminently I
think in a few weeks or maybe in a week
he if he told me that he himself she was
hidden by the organization Jose in a
Catholic school in southern France in
1943 and 1944 and just on a personal
attack I would like to add that George
Bay has been a wonderful friend to those
of us in French Jewish didn't even fly
to France over the years just in terms
of indicating resources to us help me
get my book published in France but I
think he's helped all of French Jewish
historians who've gone to Paris so again
we're very grateful and they're very
happy that you've come to the u.s. for
this time thank you
Thunder screaming take the road Andre
Solomon in doubt the soutache these are
five for save yourself associate
enclosing
solution session rabbi inni Moore who
was a community his name was a ground
age and with breat recent but one day he
was arrested by the police and the state
reserve of the matter and walk the
country and at night we found a farm and
the austere farmer if we had sleep with
a pattern in wealth and
- then also certainly different why not
enter the rabbi said but you know I drew
in - drew at home as a man said where no
matter you are a true or Spanish which
the important thing is to a good
Christian
others ask if you send losing its
aquagenic at Arkady the reason his
responses from this region City today
should have a tendency to meet ammonia
that is not losing it
the communities are found as you wish
that's good
so maybe in men consider they never
figured of the Wisconsin is a really bad
idea
Amane ladies are no other groceries
the main investor emotional contagion
don't because
let me give emotions
whenever I want her so happy to be
severable and there is an association
difference is as gentle as oh not a
friggin Mandela gave you
Palestinians euro Palestinian pepper the
hadees in arabic o illegitimate assume
different union mama can see a
civilization he cannot
so I was ship people she said I said
well they don't understand that so she
was only sick took that on - monsoon
instead he took every country to be
Saruman make the other families red
incapacitated was very busy come death
of the solution about the Adobe National
Cancer Care Act is about how good is a
such as you create the case to a society
that get some colonists either
potentially to the revolution superior
participation so the reason for that
will at least under the one we have some
projects produce a level the Monsuno to
be u-233 publish a plant in Middletown
phone wasn't directly proof whether they
typically got some activity that would
live in the officially person is not
ugly
you can see the facilities another
question resistance
Jesuitical sack race is official minute
domesticity it's just to test on this
scale at 70%
each level has utility conferences a
party of events one side and having
instructors don't be too sure about that
sir
who even said a Harlequin stranger is a
certainty factor the circus which
combination cannot film a Chevy services
at the Rosie response and the city does
it's done that's it only compute see the
result system to a new attorney Swahili
model so cupid is knowledge that such a
victim who is a real Commission is
elusive the doctor preserved a there is
a very knowledgeable about underrated
story in Africa Katya deserve article a
deterministic result the system the beta
country who said de aquila exact moment
ago Alicia come visit da man wait a
necklace
see but the problem is a good
you know that the potassium
Nilka we have a
Emil's belly
may come of salmon to some literally
doubles it's an initiative of them
represent stop it way to introduce a new
generation policy generally will result
in welcome easily debug certificate
visitors facilities of account
allocation using LP to see any event is
on how to easily use it as a cleaner
home game app with the height so many
Quakers individual conditions yet kill
extra motivation
Dante lavonte Benford Sebastian bacteria
oh no surely without a loser
no signal at all a visual deserve the
volunteer ambassador anything
differences actually made appearance of
what is equivalent to me no questions
you don't to do pathetic kappa CC
Palacio real disasters no doubt they
quit not a contest in disabled children
very active group uttered apparently so
is this also the recognition that we do
that mom
she only knows under dead experience
matters
Monsieur - gasps Oh jolly cetera state
ministers the fatality images of a
legitimately capital event material in a
shoot the coop is accepted in danger
Damo my name that they did as assistant
in the ballet she really really really
I sure have some very policies number 19
young monkey - yes Khaleesi
should we see is a cul-de-sac of the
open kitchen a little in there so Kevin
do or people missus also found the one
who canceled a big theater classically
visual image of the city to a publisher
down another two feet actually the text
the code executed if you need a director
is all they say construction do not pass
a disease not project was developed as
unit itself is distances of and what
resulted in his arrest is not so you
know and not to please okay missus
contender to be possessed of a three
person is overdue and I consume I have
this Authority L of the klappa method is
not concerned on the track second
appreciate that isn't facility value
infamous is a system which is the
maximum is exceptionally part of
automotive saturation L exacts a
shortage mobile doctor will be our
streets at the moment any second of ten
years of the emotional support really
functional finish our baptism which is a
sad fact gay Appalachia a time effective
quality
don't really want unity government in
which is met with the possible
distributed I have no problem in the
demilitarized is also a friend
immediately to depend on the physical
world domination a ready for sweetie but
emerged in May
the tantowel is no fun / - a to describe
a better reaction is really disgusting
okay then I can severely limit the data
technical calendar which is activated
here for Milli massacre is an important
local desire condition monitor service
record Sgt to talk after with us
appreciate a positive direction division
the master has legal did receive a
phenomenal investor knew some of the
factors of the sacraments of dire
necessity like instruction with Mohammed
Sheikh settler the level of utility
develops no calorie for free just a
phase of national park appeal it clever
ignorant militant Sunnis don't
understand dah under de vacaciones own
values season
you actually tomorrow to lose a column
is enough it is immediately after you
finish this event is inseparably century
because I wrote a silly video series
the doctor has a brain on mascara what
the doctor is a beta initiative dessert
after Lucy miss if your name - ojala
coordination this yet we do pastor of
series completely I don't this yoga help
from me the desert notary the series on
how the national mission Kappa D they
have to Don said she did know this is
our cached on
a memorable Kristallnacht urgently to
say they can make update them today to
let cattle representative and whenever
illusions are given the amount
Malika made disappear because a digital
era
possible contact control isn't it jiggly
visit us at our elephants damaging the
top million daily depart the week same
way and make the nativity -
I think there's a conservative you know
seeing that means knowledge
so some professional trick that I wanted
to easily envision the maximum
definitely
yeah about the vegetation on a
settlement agreement accommodation and I
want it back
no here is the destructive collusion
another little tip i conce ESL Calgary
in unipampa
assume action even a sauna sauna world
extraordinaire
media appearances on local our company
and their physical appearances utilize
this unpopular so vehicles Univision
under their two entities
to the College in Dublin in 1985 she
came here to Columbia University mr.
Robert Paxton Shekinah is an American
Association of University women's
international fellow when she was still
working on her dissertation on Vichy
France in the following four years she
ran Columbia's institute for research of
women and gender she then became the
first professor of women's studies at
the University of Georgia which teaches
now she's author of the reign of virtue
mobilizing gender and vision France and
also many articles she's currently
working on a larger project about a debt
about EMV we told ourselves that Odette
and her husband who saw a body founded
in Nice
we actually heard about that a few times
then the title of her paper today is a
question of silence
Odette about even resumed our cell and
I try not my thank yous go on longer
than my paper book they could have
really honored and privileged to be here
to be invited to be here
Harriet I can't thank you enough
Shelley and your team from really you
just a most nice I really do have to
the Polish Schwartz's here and Ruud
Kepler and I really want to say a
special thank you to whole life and they
brought her here for their work on women
in the French Resistance and oral
history they really did laser trap very
early on which made a lot I know that
certainly inspired me in terms of
thinking about how to do oral history
very quickly because I'm
from the u.s. Holocaust Memorial Museum
okay
Larry's my assets are probably gonna be
something highly illegal and somebody's
gonna sue I would like to thank Judith
cone at the Holocaust Memorial Museum
she put me in touch with Julie a little
moment and she really got me very
excited about this whole project and
then I went to the fortune of archives
at yeah and Judith was Marvis there if
you don't know about the fortune of
archives amongst people that one thinks
and you know how you learned stuff have
you remembered have you known and then
have you teach it to
my job and I know there are privileged
Thank You filmmakers okay um most
important website of the story it's a
person who survived and only survived
but has made this history of the bosom
of said it nice one that you know it's
not shrouded in silence one that is
spoken about one that has been included
and in particular has brought that story
well it's disseminating that story on
this side of the Atlantic and in France
and that angle who's here what a
beautiful cachet all the girls will not
sell in Nice Julian was kind enough to
fill me in about this history and just
send me on my way with with lots of
folks about things but truly you are one
of the most gracious and worldly wise
person who has lived this history and is
as far as I can understand it completely
uncomfortable while anger and rage which
so I thank you for everything really
elephant um for those of you who haven't
left the other side well for what's like
much this is a portrait of France and at
least was here but this is stolen from a
Holocaust Memorial museums website have
an incredible website it's been a very
teacher and so I just want to point that
nice but you also get to see the cats
which keeps us focused on that slide on
the right who's that a birdie and on the
left look that apathy name wasn't stuck
um and I would just say these are my
heroes the next one all right I'm gonna
put this up here and it's opening up
close again Calliphora that is the
Holocaust Memorial Museum if you put the
search engine you put meat soup this
will come up and the original photograph
was published in a an Hispanic newspaper
in France and the tab underneath said a
site we won't have to put up with much
longer Jews in these from the top
Menendez all day
well you know I was horrified and then I
started thinking about all this and you
know seriously when you're not sure if
you really have a lot of burdens to bear
and one of the business just I've
started this project which I do it I
have to go up to to say so it seems like
a simple question but I've been
following simple questions for quite a
while in nomina so talking about silence
nuts lands and identity and the power of
the story and all of that so first part
of this very quickly is silence about
Jewish identity and silence about
Judaism and I think there's certain
paradoxes but I will give you the quick
facts on the pessimist I'll kiss you
before that between September 1943 with
the arrival of the Gestapo in the
previous I'll administer observe and
August 1944 when that area was liberated
five hundred and twenty seven children
where hidden by this rescue network
which was based in Nice needs as a holy
a non-anomalous with fascinating history
in this period so this network was
founded by dr. Annette Rosenstock later
married Mussolini and its function
primarily the support of the local Roman
Catholic prelate was mostly remove the
reservoir cell thought the systems from
will say the Quakers to join the
Skyler's Protestant pastors everyone
Kenya as well as who look
setec french merits and bureaucrats
remotely for frozen star and a body
false identities as lay workers for the
Catholic Church and this was absolutely
essential to what they accomplished the
vessel was known as independent have any
sector of the chorale group and it was
named Marcel after mooses clandestine
name contest by name which was with you
Marcel oh that's Silas my name was
stupid enough okay in the course of a
permit to do something that did my
undergraduate student I kill them which
is to refer to start with people for
their first name I didn't happen
privilege of knowing who saw but that
wasn't stuck they are my heroes that
would have been my darling it would be
better but I didn't on the other hand I
suppose movies Julianne I feel like I
know they don't approve me but I feel
like that no no so amongst all most
poignant silences that I would refer to
of course the most poignant silence is
the disappearance of children and
if one ever has a moment and that the
fact that one is doing the right thing
you know what subject one's research
ones history I think that spells book
French children children of French
children the Holocaust the large term
which has so many photographs of
children food imported from France you
know I I just live with that I have a
photo over that and I have this book on
my desk and that's all I meet I mean it
because it keeps you very focused and I
don't really go for that sort of time
I'm a professional historian so don't
get way too personal you know a few
things I think that people can sort of
overstate that in her book on the they
want but things like I am motivated by
the passion and I think that makes my
choices and then I'm trying to remember
so the children who are hit by this this
recipe Network didn't same thing we're
all given new identities this is you
know this is one of the horrible
silences they were in and they have to
live with these silences oh death row
her memoir she was arrested
from Annunciation and purported and she
survived Auschwitz Birkenau and Bergen
Belsen
she invited nice after the after war and
she and Musa worked with jose until 1948
to help the children reunite with their
families or as in the majority of cases
of course find new homes for those whose
parents would never return and they're
never returning is of course silence
after 1948 gusano death afforded all
publicity about the role as rescuers and
have no contact with their hidden
children until the 1990s when they both
consented to give formal interviews and
reconnect with the other children who
formed an association in their honor
julienne pushing them to make the record
there to get to Nash and
Paul Raymond was declared a Righteous
among the Nations in 1991 and I think
the Righteous among the Nations scheme
well they dad today so anyway what's
this silence I forgot about with regard
to Jews and rescue and Jewishness and
silence I should just say I'm not in
fact saying that their resume master was
not Jewish
it doesn't want to put that right out
there what I am doing is trying to
question about what exactly that is what
are the admissions what are the tasks
been statins that we think of when we
make these categories so this brings
back to the photograph Musa and looked
at two people who started organizing
this network where themselves both
self-identified Jews one French the
other Syrian but proceeded by adoption
and the moving 500 children from six
months old to 16 years of they stage
were say we're from French polish
belgian austrian families Czech Romanian
both rescuers and rescued we're being
hunted out explicitly because there were
Jewish and to find this Jewish you buy
the racist ideology laws and policies of
both Nazi Germany and the Vichy France
indeed the very organizations which
hunted these Jewish children were named
and recognized for their expertise in
seeking out and removing by violence
Jews as Jews from their homes and
refugees from France the commissariat
the Castillo trees and the nice brothers
Gestapo the SS and so on in terms of
Jewish history it's important to
remember the work of Angela Donati
in this area in Italian Jewish banker
whose plan to remove a lot of
substantial portion
choose from the nice area fell through I
think we have Americans - oh that's
inherent yeah the Declaration of is they
coming out to the war and citizens of
comience the person I don't mean to be
affirmed all those questions
so yes the infamous T Network was the
successful as it was was because it was
primarily funded and assistant well
they're not exclusively by Jewish
organizations people say we'll say in
particular even the courageous and
unique sport fortitude by the local
Catholic bishop my mom was explicitly
given to Jewish children as victims of
an anti-jewish terror this whole thing
is pretty self-evident right the
children planning obliged to adopt
non-jewish identities fire but the
Jewish identities of the children were
held as sacrosanct by their protectors
was no attempt at conversion or anything
like that was in this network very very
carefully so finally in the aftermath
for children whose parents did not
return replaced almost exclusively will
actually work exclusive placed in Jewish
homes in France the US or Palestine so
this seems like an ambivalence they're
pretty straightforward Jewish resistance
or rescue history what impressed me is
how we make those determinations about
both chosen and imposed silences but
also chosen and imposed
identities how do we think about this
from the evidence
Musab that did not discuss their own
beliefs as Jews at this time we know
that he'd be brought up in the develop a
Melinda basket she the secretary of
simulated French family in Paris neither
of her parents were in any way playas in
one of the interviews
the nephew oka Odette said she was a
Parisian Tom could preset and I think
tell us a really important part of her
identity she had a period of being
interested in mysticism Jewish mysticism
in her youth when she felt she said
truly Jewish but she said was a purely
philosophical choice it doesn't make
more sense than anything else
Musa stay closer to Judaism strides life
there's no mention of either and big
marked by Judaism during the war they do
not speak of God or religious duty or
death and her members of the camp
reports events and actions pertaining to
collective nationalist Jewish identity
as poached women speaking Yiddish for
example the communist ideals of the
Yugoslav Jews and so on but Hillgrove
memoir in the interviews of death never
mentioned to be Jewish per se in order
to do even if would actually mention any
aspect of Jewish teaching more Scripture
in the wartime period yet anti-semitism
led Odette to actively claim her Jewish
identity as required by theses she
registered as a Jew in an act of
defiance
she actually chose to register knowing
the danger that was involved and that
acted the plans she described as being a
part of her character perhaps she was if
they don't want if they don't want me
that I'm going to immerse myself in this
identity that they're imposing on me
she also to herself in to work with
polish and Romanian Jewish community
they where she said her son perfectly
her people although we're not quite sure
what that was Eleonora days in medical
school she was very conscious of
anti-semitism in its material impact
three-quarters of the world was close to
what she were called so designed to
Semitism define Jewish identity
well no but most other that chose to
resist in 1942 because they believe
but they have to as human beings that
we're back to my question of what's
humanitarian here but I think somewhere
here they said this would they have to
do this as days not mastered Jews they
said they couldn't stand by and just
watch the procession they had to become
involved but then said that they were
not all prepared for the role they were
wrapped playing man Qing what she says
in the words of that time was this
independent rescue network when Musa was
assailed by an Italian priest
hooyo pen attendee wishing to confess to
him and describe the massacre of Jews in
Russia from where he just returned it's
the priest who invokes his fate
unbuttoning his soutane of swearing up a
small wooden crucifix in the face loses
complete disbelief of what he was saying
about the SS shooting Jewish children
when Musa sees a Jewish woman being
kicked to death by the valise near the
prominently Omni an event that really is
quite clearly the searing event that is
completely cathartic in terms of him
being propelled to action Musa Christ
laughs at that time my God my God why
hast thou forsaken us
but his retelling of this moment has
more on the horror of seeing that
six-year-old child watching his mother's
skull being crushed by the Milly's a
crowd of spectators standing around
doing nothing and I think this is as
important as anything else when he says
where are you why have you abandoned us
where are you and these crimes are being
committed
when Musa sought to enlist mostly
Redmon's help he appealed to him on
humanitarian grounds he said without you
I will not be able to save the children
straightforward in 1995 musa recalling
told my mom I have a Jew I come from one
of the oldest gathers in the world I'm
here to ask you to live your gospel as I
am trying to live my Bible and I'm still
trying to figure out what sort of a
challenge that wall so have you had you
characterize that Muslim at that readily
agreed to Rimmel's terms and then bring
that our hatred nor weapons to their
work this choice is not giclee explained
although we know that neither had any
experience in violent conflict armed
conflict and had to say that the
opportunity to join the arm that had
turned down the opportunity to join the
armed resistance but their commitment to
possibly pacifism is not particularly
parsed in this Pacific Jewish set of
beliefs in infused event refers to help
from the joints Jose the Quakers the
scouts she adds that they were to local
authorities who refused to participate
in the massive persecution they could
not see neither a red cross municipal
administration so on when she speaks of
her arrest and torture she says the
Germans thought was deserved but she had
taught me because I had torn hundreds of
Jewish children from their grip in this
context she doesn't mention her own
Jewish identity except in Safari she
knows that she was 29 and a doctor who'd
been fired from her job because of the
statute each week for his part Musa
looked back critically on the Jewish
leadership who had not helped the rest
of my cells children anis who had not
helped save those children and I think
in a very rare moment of this
99/5 he recalls that the jewish
community in these regarded him with a
great deal of suspicion and they really
weren't interested in helping him save
children but just looking after each
other's situation move through remembers
candies was very brief despite the lack
of jobs many jews had fled there we
think twenty-five to thirty thousand in
population back to him fifty thousand
men report even some of her medical
medical colleagues from from paris from
there whatever by the french jews who
made well the visitors needs for the
holidays before the war it was Jews from
Eastern Europe who actually stood at
particular down by the pond and his only
panic achieves that historian who's
really got the conference back in this
but produced hundreds throughout Europe
but that said this was their last refuge
it needs these easier producers were
victimized by swindlers thugs and by
denunciations one of the reason she said
she was able to evade capture for so
long was that in her own words she
didn't look too Jewish as for the
children there's no mention of their
family beliefs or practices before or
after there's much the mutinous nine
lives Moosa spoke the terrible burden
imposed by stealing a child's identity
this term she uses as part of the
process of depersonalization but of all
the aspects of the new lives in the
hidden children which you remark upon
and recorded by the other
the names of children ages health states
personality traits and so on no comment
is made about a loss of or need for
things Jewish in many ways sisters to be
expected I mean all of this was
dangerous information to be gathering at
all and after all these children lost
their parents their homes their names
their friends ever yet I found no
comment about cultural religious losses
books diet rituals prayers anything
that's sort of attached if you like
Jewishness of Jewish losses to these
children some of the children expect the
old ones express their fears about being
lost forever in the new names and
disguises and they come to from the wari
of not knowing Roman Catholic prayers
for example but we don't have any sense
of whether even the older children
missed any particular aspect of their
Jewish identity social cultural
religious not thought of as a secular
Jew was Musa my cousin committed
later in life with death and Musa we're
married by a rabbi their funeral
services were also conducted by a rabbi
Musa left his prayer book to the
survivor the husband of one of the mock
cell children with the request to say
Kaddish for him but death as far as I
know did not make similar arrangements
and she had not become involved in
Jewish life per se only wanted one that
I know of was troubled by that suicide
at the end of her life after Bruce's
death with the suicide as an act that
was conferred to Jewish beliefs and by
her area by a rabbi in the Jewish
section of Muhammad cemetery and I
really I would like to invite you all to
go to that place in their memory so musa
in 9595 speech said and I think that's
opposed to spiritual grief if I knew how
to pray I'm afraid like today for the
children your children that will never
know the the outcome of the consequences
of the tragic fate of these children who
were denounced to particular children
the children that would massacred
but since that time in terms of praying
I've not been on very good terms with
God so there are important silences that
I just wanted to underline I think I
would just say that as far as I'm
concerned a part of our obligation is
not to draw a line about how Jewish
Jewish went Jewish but to actually I
think we're obliged to respect the
ambiguity in their identities in their
work and in their own chosen lives very
very quickly yes I wanted to bring up
the next contentious question well one
which is gender all right two questions
to raise has a dense part in the history
of the person must've been recognized
and articulated as equal to goose as
well we had an example this morning of
how it has not so that was perfect thank
you very much
the second question which i think is a
little bit more interesting is in what
ways have many historical narratives of
this history's historical narratives of
this network relied on traditional
gender distortions haven't stack
written Oded nama de was the most
remarkable woman I have ever encountered
in her memoir on screen in the interview
she did with a nephew Yoga
she's not just passionate and elegant
and self-confident and articulate she
conveyed some searing truthfulness she
speaks on the page into the camera as an
implacable witness more profit than a
victim Oded survived tortured by the
Gestapo of deportation of the unique
barbarism invented by dances minutes per
canal in bergen-belsen all this and she
kept her integrity in her post-war
chosen career as a public health doctor
administrator she earned the highest
honors and in her personal life she
showed a wavering devotion to Musa the
very model of an authentic life long
enough but that was someone who was as
tough risk-taking uncompromising
decisive intellectually gifted and it's
morally sure-footed as any man so what
do we make it this her a parent's life
long deference to boost up her
acceptance of a row in his shadows in
the historical narrative of the vessel
mas death and in her later of
professional life I want to set aside
any sort of personality thing about
loses character because it has variously
been described to me as difficult to
know preparing and I just I don't want
to go there but I do want question wide
independent spirit such as the deaths
would embrace the role of Secretary to
companion to the great man instead I'd
like to focus on the
Marcel in which she seems to accept and
co-construct narrative that for granted
his leadership she chose that and
there's some silences about it in Sarah
wary of trans Moosa as recognizes the
sole founder of this network after all
the rescued network is named after the
man trenchcoat who was Lisa Lisa Marcel
and as he apparently you had a
relationship with Jose in the joint and
who first approached mostly Renoir and
won his support it seemed a qua non of
the Muslim success so no silence there
but what is notable and is never
explicitly spoke about as far as I know
actually will correct me is that the
very nature advocacy as far as I'm
concerned the very origins of the muscle
were in fact you to a dead person stuff
perhaps enough a sort of this was oh
it's my big suggestion of the day but I
don't have an institution behind me to
make this happen that the missile should
be remained reversal Silvie in Merced
and I think that would work a lot better
and be more historically accurate after
both their anuses so my question was
morally this one attempt to revise the
record in ways that might super
contemporary feminist predictions my own
included and I think the renaming that
would that would herself have this
relief rejected so let me up they have a
historical evidence even faster than I'm
doing right moment despite a bit to
claim that she was so or unprepared for
what they did is clear that the death
herself had an activist background not
only did she attend left-wing meetings
and rallies comparison
she left her medical school studies to a
refugees was back to civil war and this
wasn't any charity expedition to that
mean old go to the cops she in fact
assisted the escape of many refugees
from the internment camps we learned
about last night
particularly fits that so she was
engaged to do tender spend that time
that's fine
illegal work before 1940 when she was
fired from a public sector job for big
Jewish after the French defeat in the
summer of 1940 moose excited to see her
in Malta she's where she was working and
then he went on his way by early she too
nice
Oh death state in german-occupied parson
worked in Jewish dispensaries with
foreign Jewish refugees it was not until
November 1941 that she illegally crossed
the demarcation lines join us a nice
once there she found him in bad shape
and said about selling her some of her
possessions who could be her accordion
to help get him back on his feet
well we know that he had contact with
this Def Con the does that phone and
also try to get them American he also
tried to get an American exit visa it
was a death tempt to find employment
about which we know that most along with
her work with Jewish clinics and welfare
offices nice during this time we also
know that she learned her mother and
sisters arrest for trying to cross the
demarcation line without papers they did
not return for masters in the story of
the rest of creation two events are
always mentioned
losses meeting with Phnom Penh
attempting the Italian priest I just
mentioned and as his witnessing of this
horrific murder of the young Jewish
woman near the prom while acknowledging
that leaves we're keep on was pushing
musalla debt to the
- do something - no longer just watch
events I think it's important to retrace
but that's probable influence in their
decision and if that is the silence that
does not be talked about they could have
chosen many forms of resistance -
nonsense master all of Musa was a
graduate student at the Sorbonne and
with medieval studies and he'd been a
successful actor and travelled to New
York with the same company and contact
fraud and his mentor because that
Solomon was leading for the u.s. so why
children's rescue another silence or
death experience is listen to the story
that conversion to action she had been
an activist she graduated his doctor got
very school funds in the Paris region
didn't children was pointedly but death
had written her medical thesis on toys
and children's play it needs she worked
for the clinics where the welfare of
children was a paramount importance
everything she did you think can equally
point to her logical choice of
children's recipe over other forms of
resistance let's not forget that
agreeing not to use weapons and violence
in their struggle her death was also
acting in perfect conformity with her
oath as a doctor a decision was made to
rescue Jewish children threatened by
deportation loose out of debt to buy to
their work what we might think of as the
stereotypical masculine feminine
division of labor to be proved he worked
at the office organizing funding ID
cards missing with the bishop and other
key contacts she gathered up the orange
orphaned children brought them to the
villains yes for depersonalization the
viçosa would seem and then she delivered
the children to their new home locations
where she didn't visit them and oversaw
their welfare from September 1943 until
her arrest in April
44 well okay how was speaking rather
than maintaining these silences matter
in the overall history of Jewish
resistance on that system France which
is what we're here for four ways
it changed the networks central creation
pathology it shifts the scales of any
assessment of women in Jewish rescue and
resistance and I like a quote from when
they saying Jewish resistance in his
French Resistance it also reveals couple
Oded and losses own narrative was chosen
to highlight his actions not hers and
finally it invites us to reconsider the
complexity of gender I think and Jewish
rescue resistance activities and it's
always good to be more work needed to be
done on that and soon Mousa recognize
that no one could have done other death
did yet what she did was subsumed into
his narrative the story of mr. Marcel
not Salida laughs for example every camp
refers to him its relationship to fame
on its counterfeiting and documentary
skills that big on the run but it was a
fair food crisscross the beach and not
just nice bringing the children to
safety changing their fighting places
looking after their ended individual
needs
what for sociologists constitutes is
doing the emotional labor of the family
she's even the one who travel of all
hours to find clothes and food clothing
and food no easy matter in the nice
region at all and presumably oh that's
not recorded to make sure that Moosa
stayed in good health I mean she loved
her work this was this was part
I am not in any way and not many way
trying to diminish I should say this
very clearly mooses role along with is
he traveled to Paris he took risks you
business life every day on the street
and in the Bishop's office when Odette
was the rest of the burden language they
had they had shared fell on his
shoulders he didn't hesitate in
continuing the love um they're just it
seems to me that it's really imperative
to go back though and to look at and see
what a debt did is how that might change
the story as far as I'm concerned we
said nothing else and I've dealt with
this warp elsewhere about sounds paid
but no debts my book is gonna be about
it and um she when she was arrested was
taken by the Gestapo and tortured over
an 8-day group and she doesn't want to
talk about that she doesn't and you
respect it's a violation it is but you
know I think we just take that fact she
gave no information about the children's
whereabouts she did not give them an
offense when she was bossy to the Train
she decided to take care of the children
she she really took a sort of leadership
role you know told people have a
behavior that not be so selfish in the
midst of absolute misery a catastrophe
she really took all sorts of
extraordinary responsibilities and she
really worked throughout the period of
being in the death camps to the very
limits of her existence she nearly died
of some titles
bergen-belsen um so okay very last bit
she returned to Nate's in 1945 she took
up the work with us again at his side
she did more than survive I think she
was an exceptional person and I'm not
constitutes an exceptional woman over
the last decades feminist historians
documented multiple ways in which women
experienced who resisted the Shoah in
ways that were distinct from ants
without in any sense devaluing the
courage of suffering of Jewish men
Oded fought back against her enemy as
actively as any man could have done and
she succeeded in this struggle as a
woman a doctor and a French Jew she
bought the braced and transcended her
gender she worked in ways that Wilson
could not and she succeeded in ways that
loser could not and then having survived
impossible as it took a second depart
from the drama and history that was
reserved the Rizzo's post-liberation
life between 1945 and 1948 choose their
niece with him
largely anonymous after 1948 something I
think fairly extraordinary happened
which is moosa' and that really
completely avoided issued any contact
with the children and any publicity and
this is a sort of extraordinary silence
they were very very modest and they were
very dedicated to not taking any logs
for anything that they had done Musa
apathy is regarded as one of the great
theater critics 20th century France and
I am going to say just quite blankly and
Julia makes this I believe that mooses
cultural legacy was
- its what she did not only was she the
emotional pillar of his existence she
was the person who transcribed and typed
up every night the notes of the place
that they both attended giving him his
material for radio stomping and allowing
him to amass a unique archive to see his
magazine in ruins for French
civilization
she had a full-time job seems to me as
his secretary and a full-time job as a
public health doctor yet the question of
science in this gender analysis is not
simple Oh death battle he was no dude no
victim to patriarchy no actually SNP man
Moosa didn't manipulate her into serving
his every need in their married life any
more than he dragged her into a
resistance movement that he alone had
initiated 1940 1942 from the moment they
met but that chose her just in the
Destiny she chose to love this man and
she chose to be the actor who showed her
co-star in the very best light and she
lived her life with the unique
fierceness concealed under the most
feminine of guises she was beautiful
petite charming that I fell in love with
her when I saw her in this interview she
was completely epiphysial but she was
always moose as equal she embraced sons
but she was not like thank you very much
as a result of these initiatives by mid
April of 1942 there were only 55 Jewish
children left at this camp of Sultan's
and women's section their children
originally there to being over 500
children they are the previous winter
one of those a official went so far as
to report that well the problem of
children in the camps can never be
considered virtually resolved end quote
it's true as we now know that these
children were released from one health
into one another one since these Jewish
residential homes were also at be
targeted by the Gestapo and the melis
but there was some time before those
raids began and during that period of
relative calm before the storm
these children regarding their new homes
is a sort of paradise to cite the
testimony of one students upon these
tests
witnesses from her Holocaust fantasies
yes as Jewish life became more
precarious in 1943 through 44 Jewish
organizations did turn to clandestine
operations according to Andre Solomon
the passage from a legal to a
clandestine insistence was not as abrupt
as people later thought as she said in
here I mentioned just quoting her George
with a quote George they presented the
passage into early guarantee was not
accomplished in a single blow and no one
felt that they were undertaking anything
momentous rescue simply necessitated the
construction of links of chain
nevertheless the move toward an
underground existence that is
substantial which in talent stands of
open resistance to the vision regime did
require a shift of thinking and it may
well be that by 1943 through 44
disparity in Jewish organizations
altogether might well have been the best
strategy still as I think while these
papers suggest the aim of Jewish
organizations was not only to save Jews
as individuals but to save Judaism
indeed this is the major reason why
there were such great resistance to the
idea of dispersing these children among
Christian institutions alone among
families here in Jackson specular
my shears and avoided this alternative
because of his orthodoxy actually she
didn't really get to talk much about
that but that was the reason that these
children were still in this home at this
late date but I actually think this
hesitancy was shared by all the Jewish
belief investor organizations even
though they may have defined Judaism
quite differently as one of those a
worker put it the rationale for keeping
Jewish children with Jewish homes was to
quote ensure a better education for the
children and to give them a feeling of
belonging to a group and of being bound
to one another by ties of solidarity and
flow and this factor together with the
practical problems involved with
dispersing the children was the major
reason why some of these homes continue
to exist even into 1944
despite the fact that it's probably true
Jewish that the leader should have no
and that it would then that at this
point to have just make sure that those
children have been dispersed although
again is Harriet raises this point
Shearson was just about even these
children in this home were about to be
sent to Switzerland I just want to build
out a rather coloureds notion of
silences to raise a few points for us to
think about his possible avenues for
future research especially if we have
any graduate students here in the
audience one is a topic as
on multiple occasions today the role of
women all three of these papers are
focused to some extent on Jewish women
on race Alimentum body Ciara and
Hadassah Shearson who actually won that
race the same question about fairness
Miranda did in her paper but all of them
were acting as social workers and I
would argue or suggested the role of
women as social workers both before and
during the war is an issue that remains
relatively unexplored Marian Kaplan I'm
not sure if she still hears done some of
this work for jury but I'm not aware of
it mean you could get anything
maybe more there are some recent work on
this topic at the same time you need to
think about the role of given social
workers more broadly
since Catholic and Protestant women
shoot played a huge role than the rescue
of Jewish children we will write your
name with the era of post affiliate
partners in early eighties in
southwestern France member roni we saw
quite a bit of last night in the film
fix that pierre Sauvage presented to us
that she was the individual leader of
the syma the constant relief
organization while these women were
critical in providing relief in the
camps and in fortunately arranging his
faith of Jewish children to Switzerland
so again I think this role of women in
general the social workers is somewhat
of an understanding the italic in
looking at rescue and resistance a
second side was mentioned by Miranda
polar is religion here at Jackson has
suggested that we don't really know a
great deal about Jewish religious life
and tradition yet in the papers of
necrosis twice and trial that have
become available in recent years there's
reached material on the role of the
rabbinate and chaplains individuals like
grand rabbi renamed Herschel ER and lay
leader but I'm going to figure the
writer and in smeg who served as one of
the leaders of the Scout Movement word
arduous way to keep Jewish religious
life alive under the
trying circumstances third although all
three of these papers are about Jewish
rescue each of them highlights the
degree to which Jewish rescue would not
have been possible without the help of
Christians both Catholics and
Protestants I think Renee this morning
and it was nasty mentioned how you can't
really separate these two resistance
movements Marana kohler points to
helping the archbishop of nice Monsignor
Ramon who had been an ardent supporter
of dishy
but increasingly became disenchanted in
part because of the roundups of Jews but
again as we've heard in a number of
papers here today
a large number of Christians played a
critical role in Jewish rescue again
from Pierre so bashas film clips we've
already heard about the activities of
tears from a and the last word Monsignor
surely a when senior savage terri penrod
poop susan Zuccotti talked about avenger
main live here who we didn't hear much
about that she was mentioned in some of
the film clips as well and then among
Protestants past a Bergner because your
trophy has to 0 and then Donna Lowry
Americans as well the head of the YMCA
in actually pierce of ours also
mentioned Quaker organizations all of
these into
and the organization's made
representative the young ETA at the end
seemed odd the Quakers they all
experienced the same transformation of
going from a legal to a clandestine
existence during this paper legal
existence of helping the Internet in the
camps to increasingly giving were lost
papers and ultimately helping to ferret
the refugees and especially the children
into Switzerland I think what's
important here is that despite the fifth
at Bishop was a period of unprecedented
anti-semitism it was also a period of
unprecedented interfaith cooperation
we've seen this I think across the board
but this interfaith collaboration
especially between Jews and Christians
he had far-reaching consequences in the
post-war period in terms of fostering
interfaith dialogue
finally when there's silence there
George they pointed to is the
oscillation connection I can't help but
mention this since I've also worked on
the history of our station Jew but
according to you today a very strong
sense of Jewish people that received in
large measure by her all station
background and especially her sympathy
for science in the
I think that's true of grand rabbi at
B'nai Hertzler
as well throughout the 1930s of station
Jewish leaders who take it are much more
a broad position with the Arabs are
fighting anti-semitism and also with
regard to pressure and jewett French
Jewish organizations to make more
particular more vigorous and generous
stance toward their besieged helping
their besieged refugee co-religionists
who were fleeing to France from central
in Eastern Europe it was a lot to a
large extent these leaders in groups
like the experimental the Jewish Scouts
which included a disproportionate number
of AA station Jews than how to sustain
what hundreds Allen called the spiritual
creases dense under Vichy
thank you very much
that I grew up knowing as much about you
know I don't know whatever research but
there's another side I
I also happen to know a treacherous
Oh
so you'll agree with me in petition and
change the whistle name
Oh
thank you
it's about got our tip you later
circles and deacons not so much to the
fact that the woman can be the problem
anymore
but the kinds of questions that were
raised by these women to say two things
about that one is that the fire
the dedication the worst thing leaders
about the children who were deported you
can't avoid that aspect of once you
start studying but the other thing is
there are other really you know the
focus of the class Barbie trial has to
do with a lot of kind of thing but it's
to mothers of these youth confound
Barbie in Bolivia Runner and fortunately
and there's tons of stuff on them that
needs to be made articulated there's the
children of these youth the whole four
hours but it starts
I just like to say that one thing that's
come out of this conference for me kind
of opened my eyes to a point which is
that the one of the reasons that Jewish
rescuers have not been recognized
acknowledged described some of the
information is actually lost is because
they themselves did not want the
recognition and I had never realized
that before I found it for the first
time in my work just be a second place
in my working Joseph axe because Jones
with fast did not want any recognition
for what he did
alright this is the first time I've
heard that then I hear the same thing
today from Anthony Solan and from Odette
and Musa and I wonder from how many
others but it's interesting for a number
of reasons
because it's a partial factor in the
lack of recognition and the loss of
information about these classes at
clandestine operations which after all
perfectly nested but it's also I think
something we might think about in terms
of a degree of psychological scarring
that these people had dealing day after
day after day with the kind of work that
they were doing the kind of people they
were trying to help thank the tragedies
that they were witnessing I don't know
why one would not want recognition I
know that Joseph bass did receive medals
for his military resistance and he wore
them very proud but he did not want to
talk about the work he had done as a
rescuer and I until today thought he was
the only one
I'm not sure if I teach English rescuers
and you mentioned they did a five you
know to the Arab ones or the Christian
some Christians may be alleged my
component
partly yes a poet that
not sure their Jewish recipe words in
France
I was certain coming here that I would
be the only one from the hazelnut said
who would speak having known Odette at
the age of ten when we met briefly for a
few hours of time for her to take me and
my brother from East become and to see
her the next time she nearly 50 years
later 48 or 49 years later when I
discovered her real identity she was
initially presented to me as CV the
Lateran working for the diocese Catholic
Diocese of nice and I assumed that she
was Catholic and that my being and my
brother both of us being taken to come
to the reimburse Elaine where we were to
spend three years I I always assumed
that this was the intervention of the
church and was totally ignorant
the existence of their there is no
muscle until I had a chance to learn all
about it through a chance encounter in
Jerusalem of one Lucia Lazar
the well-known French Israeli historian
upon hearing my story smile that means
he said this is not your your history
and he proceeded to tell me about but
it's late and it's a complex and rich
story and it's getting late I will
simply say that I share Miranda's
attempt to take Odette out of life and
aroma and put her in full light I may
not tilt the other way I would simply
say that both of them really deserve the
full light of recognition and of
remembrance for what they did
there is a point that escapes I think
the history and that it's only I think
recently come to light that there is
another person who has played a very
critical role in the history of the
resume how said this person whose name
has come up once or twice in the last
day or so
Maurice by now the representative of the
joint a one of perhaps several
representatives of the joint who meant
Moussa in June or July 1942 I should say
the two of them were friends they had
known each other at the cell button in
the late thirties Moosa was seized by
all of the experiences that were under
cited and many others the I'm not a
zombie incident the tale brought by the
ammonia Italia from the Russian front
but he was full of anger he was full of
despair but he didn't really know what
to do about it he felt it was something
that they should he and no that should
react and do something about it really
have an idea of what and it is Maurice
Brenner who is sort of the scarlet
pimpernel who I think deserves story
history of his own who told Musa and
this chance meeting that occurred in
about June of July 1942 about larezo
garage and what was being done and had
been done by him and his many associates
in the preceding six or 12 months namely
the soft ash is also and who recounted
the experience of gar l in dealing with
the Catholic Church and listing all the
eminent Catholics that he did
avec
later yeah you know and who inspired
Musa to undertake a similar effort in
Nice and furthermore he engineered a
meeting of Garrett and Musa that
occurred in probably August of 1942 in
which in the course of several hours got
out briefly fully briefed Musa on what
he had done in the preceding 12 months
or so and dispersing children from the
camp ever from these homes that had been
created for them by the Jose and all the
other measures including spirit things
the children to Switzerland so armed
with this information and this example
and the rather you might say technical
assistance provided by Durrell
Musa proceeded to
mount his own Network and he did so
insisting at the time to bear out that
he had to do so on his own as an
independent operator and he was very
very strong about this partly reflecting
his personality but partly also as a
measure of security it made no sense for
him to operate under the aegis of the
Wraith of gorillas with the all of the
risks attended in doing so and the
decisive fact that really wrapped the
whole thing together is the assurance
that marefriend air could provide him
that money would be forthcoming that the
funds would be available and he was not
the only beneficiary of this assurance
Corral and others similarly but the
availability of financing was a critical
factor in the success of this and many
other enterprises that we have talked
about yesterday and today
I had mentioned you Renee earlier today
this issue of the financing it's really
very important because the money came
from the Joint Distribution Committee
but suppose I merrily through the Eugene
and in the southern shall be individual
organizations we changed a great deal of
autonomy and I think in terms of this
whole question of why maybe they're
recognizing juice is problematic but
maybe again where do you draw the line
should even remember all along there who
was the head of the youth in the
southern zone recognized as he actually
I mean some resistors have recognized to
him as a resistor or so many and maybe
it wasn't Maurice Renard is cousin yeah
yes they were so okay and they were very
very close and again I think this raises
the whole question of the usage which
actually was not mentioned much today
but I think this amendment were talking
about Jewish recipe because the money
came from there even on the th but the
end was funded program with Jewish money
so you can't again can't really separate
these organizations
and very very quickly I forgot to say
and do something this is the army class
that the and social class felt it's a
little boy I don't know another story
it's a very very very poignant story but
problem and I think is on beta this is I
think very important touching to the
whole story of rescue Denise he our nose
really gave His life to save his wife
and children could I have a next I don't
know if you recognize this this is
Julian Olga was the name I think you got
farther Joerg yeah and your brother
George
so again it's a reminder this is what
this history is all about and I think
you look very well there
can I see the other photo again three
years later before leaving the United
States I just I'm not trying to still
show this but just to say that we keep
remembering what it's actually all about
this is the smile that we can see the
smile I I have a question
one always knew about this true eyes oh
you know Gavin and a body but actually
your comments made clear that it looks
as though
Marcel was built more or less upon the
knowledge yes the big difference that
the original garage was composed of 20
30 50 people if not more so he had the
vast array of people that he had
assembled and who at one time or another
working them closely though isn't my
cell is essentially based on the work of
two people and two younger assistance
provided by the oh say who we're very
early in the game arrested and
disappeared
I should underline as well that is a
very major contributor to the success of
their enterprise with the contributions
but was there any further contact
between the two of them after this
meeting of August fortitude
interventions cover between Calvin there
was one meeting between in wartime in
1942 and after that they never met at
the end of the war yes the kingdom of
live no so it was the one briefing that
he gave and that was sufficient to move
out to take off and proceeded to
organize
and
and Yahoo said said
go graders who wanted to
so I never mentioned whatever mentary
immediately after the war Musa and
Odette work together to find the
children get the back to families if not
promised by new families and then when
they were doing that process they were
connected with Jose and gab but in 48
they handed over their organization
which have we got independent absolutely
open to that point they sort of handed
it back to God
the sleeve just before departure
that may be so but the experience
acquired between beginning of 1943
January and 40 June or July 46 which the
basis on which Guerrero was in the
position to speak from considerable
experience to someone who when they met
still that's only the vaguest notions of
what you do absolutely there's going to
be a reception afterwards so maybe some
of this we can continue on
a fascinating concept that maybe you
challenge tough you just all of us
okay if none of them wanted with your
mission okay maybe none of them wanted a
middle of persons etcetera etcetera I
wonder
true that
this story to be told then why do I
wonder collective means you should go to
the CDJs be archived from their
testimonies of most of these people many
of those psychological
Jews were trying to make their first
earth they just we're not hurt nobody
was ready to listen so I'm wondering if
the fact that they look for recognition
is the right way
like really desperately on the run all
the time constantly under risk when she
was denounced arrested and disappeared
he went to Paris tried together there's
nothing to be done inspector police he
literally even with his connections the
Archbishop of a mall said to him look
you know this is disastrous
we found her safe place at site least
you need to go there for a while and he
said look when you in the First World
War like one yeah did you leave your
post and he said I'm not leaving my post
so what he had to do was it nice he
asked four times the bull the masses
that were being sent and he used to go
from master-master mass you know it was
a place to be and we have to sleep on
the floor of a school I mean it was
desperate measures to avoid being picked
up the rest I just wanted a force I
completely agree with it one a one other
dimension that hasn't been mentioned is
when you are deemed to have been a
member of the French Resistance in
France you have all sorts of benefits
all sorts of support all sorts of
subsidies that you can receive these
were not given to rescuers and I knew I
knew meds and refused very well worked
in the garden and I remember her telling
me trying to get some of these benefits
and how difficult it was the second
thing which was relevant to the question
is I think all the Jewish rescuers felt
the weight of everything they had failed
to do more than anybody else would have
felt I don't think there's a single one
of them who wasn't so conscious of what
they weren't able to achieve so they
weren't gonna put themself forward and
lastly there's a characteristics applies
for all the rescuers you show me a
boastful rescuer and I'll show you a
liar
but connect I don't I mean I'm not going
to completely disagree about this but
for Moosa and now death and I and agree
we should just make this all a question
of personality but at the same time it's
very hard to know some independent
variables that are going to work not a
social scientist but in their case what
they had both been through and
particularly for debt and and they
really were such a such it was too
painful what they had been through it
was too painful what she had gone
through in the camps and you know that
as far as I can understand and I don't
they both had a breakdown of sorts so to
hold their history back it's not just a
question whoever very models we're not
going to talk about that and she you
know you could go into benefits achieve
that and he was recognized in the
resistance all of that they very much
chose to cut themselves off and they
reinvented this new life and I think
that was very very important it's not
just a question of modesty it was really
a question of also self-protection and
then I think the ethical choice for them
was also these children when they when I
first heard but how could you possibly
leave the children how could you
possibly have no contact with them what
is that but I understand far better now
that they really believed this was too
painful period these children need to be
allowed to go